[Musik]
kilian wirkt auf den ersten blick wie
ein ganz normaler junge vom land berlin
scheint friedlich und ausgeglichen wenn
sie gitarre spielt
[Musik]
und auch dominik macht einen ruhigen
eindruck
doch diese drei kinder aus ganz normalen
schweizer familien haben alle das
gleiche problem sie sind unkonzentriert
und hyperaktiv sie leiden am sogenannten
aufmerksamkeitsdefizit syndrom
adhs und das dagegen eingesetzte
medikament ritalin machen schlagzeilen
was ist los sind unsere kinder krank
oder spinnt unsere gesellschaft was ist
adhs überhaupt und warum ist es so im
gespräch
eine suche nach antworten
[Musik]
der neunjährige kilian ist ein
spezielles kind er eckt immer an
vor drei jahren wurde bei ihm ein
starkes adhs diagnostiziert
seine eltern haben ihr leben umgestellt
und sind mit ihm zu einer bauernfamilie
aufs land gezogen
die siedlung haben wir grund um während
merkt es gott überhaupt nicht da ist
dann wirklich sehr blog nennt merkel
verliert so süß lache ich habe immer
gesagt 80 meter aufgestellt
portman dann im bunde aufgrund des etwas
sehe ich dass mir ein wohnungswechsel
macher und händen hat zufalls immer
wirklich auf einem bauerhof zurücklegt
vermieter unter drin wohnen die burg und
mir sind wirklich übernehmen
der umgang mit kilian war von anfang an
schwierig er war schon als kleinkind
anders als die anderen
ja ich unruhig sie soziale hat glitter 2
war es hätte zu ruhige spiele könne
mache sache wo andere sind auf beckham
hat er kaputt macht aber nicht böswillig
welles' und an müllers nötig minute sie
nie sie in die kraftlose ihre grüne
trikots und somit machte sich natürlich
unbeliebten trindade am us-markt sozial
vor allem und wenn man irgendwo war im
restaurant autostadt immer umgesetzt
wird also irgendwo hin man merkt es
läuft anders
kilian ist immer ein bisschen fahrig bei
ihm passiert alles gleichzeitig im kopf
[Musik]
er ist ungeschickt zappelig und impulsiv
in der natur fühlt er sich wohl
hier ist seine welt gerät am anfang sehr
schwierig sie und ich habe mich
entschieden da noch linux ist haben sich
nur wenige können wäre das sehr traurig
aber habe ich so sagen kann einfach
nicht anders
aber es ist wie sich aufgaben kilian ist
hilfsbereit und sensibel
er leidet wohl am meisten darunter dass
er so schnell die nerven verliert und
seine eltern leiden mit sie haben sie
schon oft vorwürfe gemacht
wenn man von uc immer muss chöre ihr
hund das kind nicht im griff ihr könnt
das nicht es ist mir alles kaputt denn
etwas schuld flügelmann dank ich weiß
gar nicht da ziehe ich erschweren eigene
kränzler obwohl ich weiß ich hab regel
ich bin strukturiert ich weiß das buch
das alles das spüre ich als mutter aber
ja den habe ich schuld fühlt als müsste
eigentlich so ich will viel ich in
fehler machen dem consult mutter und da
ich dann noch zu daheim bin
ohne berufstätig er da mache ich mir da
noch mehr vorwürfe
bis zu dem zeitpunkt als diagnose kam
dann nicht so dieser aber darum und die
eltern natürlich ist für die helfer
seien die high school habe jetzt den
major eigentlich wenn man es nicht
schafft es dem kind das mache ich mir
vorstelle oder besser gesagt wird um
grafik oder großeltern eigentlich so
vorstellen wie es sein ziel
und das ist er mit charme mit mit mit
versagt mit inkompetenz und der glaube
ich habe ne alte begriff wenn meine der
wirklich beim namen nennt wenn man mir
sagt was sie ihrem kind hat es hatte
hannes und mit der eine mögliche gurt
der cx1 sei heiße hautklinik eine
scharfe 1000 das dreieck typisch mann
geschaut nicht ein schreibt das hält
sagen endlich sanieren
das ist alles problemlos von sika
beschäftigt sich seit 25 jahren intensiv
mit adhs und steht dem heutigen buben
sehr kritisch gegenüber
zusammen mit seinem team hat er eine
abklärung zentrum für psychische
probleme bei kindern aufgebaut
hunziker findet es werde heute zu viel
und so schnell adhs diagnostiziert
aber das ist das phänomen gibt ist für
ihn unbestritten
was ist denn überhaupt adhs es ist
definiert die symptome gruppe wo
konzentrationsstörung eigentliche basis
ist und nach abgeleitet von ihrer
konzentration stören aufmerksamkeit
betracht die spitäler sind und was ihr
auto ist der senat in bezug auf ihre
reaktionsfähigkeit lindsay war als
impulsiv bezeichnet also sie heißt auch
wir nicht im griff
reagiere sehr schnell und impulsiv und
entsprechen
denn wenn sie durch ihr bisher die die
etwas abgelenkt war dass sie sich sofort
am ort aber nur ein fokussierter damals
sollte
alle diese symptome sind bei familie
schira die bestens bekannt mit allem was
sich daraus auch noch ergeben kann
bei der 14-jährigen celine wurde in der
ersten klasse adhs diagnostiziert
ihre kleine schwester marielle ist nicht
betroffen
aber die hyperaktivität und vor allem
die impulsivität von céline haben das
familienleben stark geprägt
sie hat die grund sie hat immer
permanent die ganze aufmerksamkeit vor
allem gefordert also mit nudeln fertig
700 auch mit jeder verbraucht hat und
habe gar nicht sagen warum
heute ist das unvorstellbar celine
unterscheidet sich kaum von anderen
teenagern aber erst einmal kam alles
noch viel schlimmer
vor allem als die schule begann ich oft
nicht so lustig sein frauchen signale
beschrieb oder was ich von mir weg und
dann habe ich jeden tag schlimmer
jeden tag die ich aggressiv oder sie hat
sich auch wenn man verweigert es ist das
hier hat zu allem nein sie hat auch wenn
man probieren und sauberer jedem
revitalisiert und ich bin natürlich ein
produkt wurde ja klar
und dann ist der moment oberzell ihn
wegen wir uns über ihre zimmer brocken
ist und sie hat morgen also mit schwung
kommt nur noch die symptome sind gemein
und schimpfte ganztag und ich gebe mir
so mir und niemand hat mich lieb das ist
natürlich eine katastrophe besonders
kind wohl der klassik mal die quadro fx
die positive serie langsam zurück und
die negativen zu an die tiere spiralen
in den fluss so ver selb start und ich
glaub du dich denn vor allem den see
lampe begraben verdienen sind das
defizit der einfach das sagt schwank
vielhaber ganzen halle risch index cfnai
machen alles voraus was sie machen ist
falsch und die dtsg nutzer wald wo alles
anders gesehen wie schlecht die bibel
celine war damals acht jahre alt und in
der zweiten klasse
sie wurden psychologisch betreut ihre
mutter gab den job auf doch die
situation spitzte sich innert kürze
dramatisch zu zum eklat kam es wegen
gurkensalat einem detail im menüplan
die haare hat sie uns griff wir verrückt
wurde gemeinheit jetzt versprochene
energie ich mache salat umziehen ruft
aus gefreut dass ich die einzig freude
dem skistar und jetzt können sie heißen
gruselige fracht und nicht einmal der
salat aus egweil und depeche mode oft
ganz großer weiter welt und dann hat
sich schwester abgeschlagen irgendwie
finde ich kann mich verjagt sitzen
glaubt nahtlos ich ganz auf das kind
losen verschlafen wie ihrer verzweiflung
und die andere wurde zum haus geladen
hatte man ihr schaut euch geschafft das
nehme ich habe alle register zog ich
habe alles probiert ich konnte einfach
nicht ich weiß nicht
nichts ging mehr bei den gratis
die therapeutin stellte eine
fremdplatzierung zur diskussion
aber alle waren sich einig dass man
celine in dieser situation nicht
abschieben dürfen
der einzige ausweg in diesem moment ein
versuch mit dem starke medikament
ritalin
ich erwarte nicht im groll und zum
hersteller und ihre dank januar wird das
htc jetzt frei und im sinne ihrer zeit
sondern selbstbestimmt und sich der
erste name taxi sieht ewigkeit und
trikots sind und bei uns uns mit lux ich
bin so erlös sie und ich habe wieder
darüber nachdenken und das haben wir
jetzt brauchen situation relativ gut
beruhigt serien reagierte gut auf
ritalin und nimmt es nun seit sechs
jahren
ritalin gegner finden es
unverantwortlich kinder mit dem
medikament zu behandeln kinderarzt aus
franziska sieht das weniger ideologisch
soffin will muss das medikament richtige
arbeitet wenn es wirklich prima wenn wir
das aus schülern die das alleinige
möglichkeit und aus asche und und und
undifferenzierte setzt zum teil beginnt
war einfach nimmer mit der lag sie sich
überhaupt offene situation ist demnach
das medikament wirken der bereitschaft
massiv stärken besser ein wundermittel
ist ritalin aber nicht es wirkt
erwiesenermaßen nicht bei allen kindern
und vor allem ist bei vielen kindern gar
nicht klar ob sie wirklich ein adhs
haben
bei dominik zum beispiel der 12 jährige
lebt mit seiner familie in zürich
[Musik]
das zwinkern gehörte von klein auf zu
ihm sein vater hatte es früher auch
dominik war ein lebendiges fröhliches
kind bis zum schuleintritt
dann gab es auch bei ihm probleme er war
ein schlechter schüler und fand keinen
kontakt
[Musik]
von re gruppe mit dem namen und der
heißt einfach alles explodiert berichten
fiel auf sie berührte los der abfangen
ina kremer bevormunde claudio macht dass
claudio macht ist es und wenn die gaudi
haben leiden heiterem halten books lesen
oder mit bild zusammen
[Musik]
in der schule lief es nicht gut
zu hause nahmen die spannungen zu vor
zwei jahren mussten die eltern nicht
mehr weiter
dominiks noten wurden besser er konnte
sich tatsächlich besser konzentrieren
aber in der schule blieb er ein
außenseiter und gegen die spannungen zu
hause half das medikament auch nicht
dominiks eltern suchten weiter und
stießen auf ein exotisches angebot
eine auszeit auf der alb ohne eltern und
ohne ritalin fünf wochen in der natur
ohne fernsehen und gameboy weg von der
reizüberflutung die eigenen bedürfnisse
wieder spüren
[Musik]
dies ist die therapie idee der
sinnstiftung einer deutschen
organisation für dominik war die zeit
auf der alb ein einschneidendes erlebnis
und ein wendepunkt in seinem leben die
natur hat ihn auch den menschen wieder
näher gebracht
durch diesen vortrag über die alb werken
seine schulkameraden dass er geissen
käse machen und holzhacken konnte
plötzlich war er auch in der schule
besser akzeptiert dominique nimmt heute
kein ritalin mehr und trifft sich
häufiger mit freunden
das hat sein verhältnis zu seinem bruder
claudio sie entspannt adhs wird heute
viel schneller diagnostiziert und
ritalin häufiger verschrieben als früher
eine entwicklung die oscar problematisch
wird das ist schwierigkeit dass man im
moment dieser gesellschaft mit dem
begriff die lockerung gott und rasch
neue energien einfach den quasi wird die
etiketten anhänger das ist klassische
persönlich muss jedes kind immer wieder
selber gesehen und die kinder bezogen
das hätte es adhs und bin ein anderer
ich bin sicher und das eigentlich nicht
genau ich schätze
und 20 metern ist der bauantrag einfach
mehr und mehr ins bewusstsein dass man
vom 1 nach oskar und sich den fragen was
ich denn jetzt mit einem strauß von
möglichkeiten die beste möglichkeit die
beste offerte und mit einem hinter acht
anders kinderarzt meinrad ryffel in
münchenbuchsee
er hält viel von ritalin und verschreibt
es auch häufig das hat ihm den namen
ritalin papst eingebracht riffel betreut
mit seinem psychologen zusammen etwa 300
kinder
er will nicht von einem adhs boom reden
betroffen seien weltweit unverändert
etwa vier bis fünf prozent
das nimmt nicht zu aber was zunimmt ist
dass mir dieses gitters für alle mieter
bietet hyperaktive vor allem
aufmerksamkeit störte betroffener und
sehe zu dass ich hilfe geworden
das stimmt mit großer vor allem auf
diese nicht hyperaktive form von adhs
hat sich raffl in letzter zeit
konzentriert dass auch verträumte kinder
wie daniela unter der
aufmerksamkeitsstörung leiden wurde
lange nicht erkannt weil sie ruhig sind
und nicht anecken
aber auch sie leiden und haben ein
schlechtes selbstwertgefühl daniela
nimmt seit vier jahren er sucht jetzt an
der lehrstelle aber einfach ist es nicht
als meinrad ryffel vor 35 jahren
angefangen hat meinte man bei adhs
handle es sich um einen geburtstag heute
geht man von einer unterfunktion im
gehirn aus welche man mit medikamenten
ausgleichen kann
die kontroverse um ritalin findet riffel
viel zu emotional
kinder jugendliche oder das habe wieder
flugs erwachsene bisher für die eliten
drucken zu verbessern und denke ich habe
das ganz wesentliche das mit der brille
besichtigen normal aussieht ich das
natürlich sehr groß
der ritalin konsum in der schweiz nimmt
zu
meinrad ryffel erstaunt dass eigentlich
nicht ja dass man ausgerechnet während
die betroffene kind also jetzt
erwachsene ohnehin begriffe würde
richtig behandeln und er behelligt haben
die montrada ausgegangen dass wert war
in tat und wahrheit ist wahrscheinlich
länger gebraucht die dass die tür
halbhoch im moment für besucher sie
sicher nachholbedarf
und warum hämmerer nachholbedarf wenn
wir doch langsam gemerkt wer mit ihrer
stützung richtig dosiert vor allem
richtig dosiert und ganz wichtig kultur
darüber sprachen also dass immer wieder
kontrolliert ist nur durch digitale oder
so die ich dass er hilfe maßnahme
bewährt
zurück zu kilian in die innerschweiz
ohne ritalin käme er wohl kaum zurecht
aber es löst bei weitem nicht jedes
problem
[Musik]
kilians eltern haben alle erdenklichen
maßnahmen getroffen
sie versuchen im klare strukturen zu
geben
er geht in einem puppenspiel therapie
und trotzdem eines seiner probleme ist
dass er ziemlich schnell handgreiflich
wird wenn er nervös ist
darum haben ihn die eltern einen boxsack
ins zimmer gehängt
[Musik]
bruckschen viel aus mitgefühl so ruhig
war kilian früher nie seit dem zweiten
kindergarten also seit drei jahren
bekommt er medikamente er findet es
hilft kilians mutter ist
krankenschwester
sie hat lange gezögert ritalin
einzusetzen homöopathie ausprobiert
schüssler salz kinesiologie die ganze
natur sache oder halt auch die andere
therapieformen ausprobieren er sieht
einfach nicht der erfolg braucht der
abbruch tandberg bietet immer noch und
dann hat uns den wirkliches ritalin ganz
vorsichtig zeit es gab dies noch aber es
ist wirklich der absolute letzte anka
für uns sie wenn unser nacht lang
gedanken gemacht seller marcel amanit
mehr in uns als eltern wirklich zeit wer
mir es nicht ausprobiert einfach mal
vier wochen ausprobieren würde mir nie
besser ob sie liebens druck nicht
weniger wird werde
kilian bekommt nun 36 milligramm
konzerte pro tag etwas ähnliches wie
ritalin
das ist der viel für ein so kleines kind
aber seither haben die konflikte auf dem
pausenplatz ein bisschen abgenommen
es hat eine weile gedauert bis man das
richtige medikament gefunden und die
dosierung optimal eingestellt hatte
reizvoll ist kilian aber immer noch
[Applaus]
seine integration in die schule hat viel
zeit und geduld gebraucht
kilians eltern sind dauernd im kontakt
mit der lehrerin
sie hat in der klasse immer wieder
darüber diskutiert wie die schüler und
schülerinnen mit kilian am besten
umgehen soll steht und die alte tablette
lokalität die klage und sind mit sechs
klassen und so und jetzt viel besser
modells wenn wir so zeugten der laden so
ein projekt das jetzt dabei untreu
besser wurde
und jetzt macht das immer bestreitet
dass mich nicht sehr italienisch für
kilian ist die schulsituation
frustrierend er kann sich schlecht
konzentrieren und kommt mit dem
schulstoff kaum nach das macht ihn
aggressiv er wird zwar integrativ sonder
geschult das heißt in der normalen
klasse von einer weiteren lehrperson
unterstützt aber dem vergleich mit den
kameraden ist er trotzdem ausgesetzt und
dabei schneidet er nicht gut an
nicht ganz ruhig geld
jetzt steht ein lehrerwechsel an und als
zusätzliches fach kommt englisch hinzu
all das macht kilian im moment große
sorgen
die eltern fragen sich immer öfter opfer
kilian eine sonderschule nicht besser
wäre
seit das konzept der integrierten schule
durchgesetzt wird versucht man wieder
möglichst viele kinder in den
regelklassen zu behalten
aber die meisten lehrer sind keine
sonderpädagogen die eltern der
mitschüler drücken auf die einhaltung
des lehrplans das gibt probleme und
bewirkt auch das auffällige kinder heute
schneller abgeklärt werden immer mehr
sachsen ohne worte frischt und die wird
jetzt muss er 50 prozent verdienen
americas brücke stetig adhs und durch um
zunehmend und vollständiges zu schauen
und zu einer armen kinder lehrerinnen
und lehrer womit ein älteres kind hätte
spurs hatte dallas zurück zu dominik
schulalltag auch im zürcher schulhaus
manneck
dominiks leistungen haben sich ohne
ritalin wieder verschlechtert aber das
nehmen die eltern in kauf die
fünftklässler müssen einen aufsatz
schreiben
das macht dominik große mühe
während die mitschüler zwei seiten
schreiben knorz dominik am ersten absatz
herum
adhs symptome sind auch an dieser schule
ein thema vielfach ist im lehrerzimmer
erst einmal unklar um was es geht wenn
ein kind probleme macht zudem ist die
grauzone gerade bei adhs sehr groß
die statistik mit adhs nöth speziell
aufgeführt werden als kind mit
behinderung oder sind mit speziellen
eigenschaften aber es hat in jeder
klasse sicher als 23 und wo steht für
oder weniger stark mit dem problem zur
hand für die lehrer ist es wichtig
unterscheiden zu können ob ein kind eine
aufmerksamkeitsstörung hat oder ob es
einfach schwierig tut und
disziplinarische maßnahmen nötig sind
schulleiterin marion hat befürwortet
deshalb dass man die kinder abklären
lässt das adhs behindert ist viel
möglich erklärt person anders auf das
kind zum anderen gab es scharfe zu
mittelfinger
darum empfiehlt das adhs abklären
gemacht werden
auf der anderen seite befürchten eltern
natürlich dass ihr kind stigmatisiert
wird durch eine adhs diagnose in einer
zeit wo alle erfolgreich sein müssen
darum steigt der druck auf die schule
auf die eltern und natürlich auch auf
die schwächsten die kinder eine unselige
entwicklung aber eine bei der eine
schuldzuweisung wenig bringt juli sowie
der indikator für für die worte
gesellschaft und viel von der erwarte
kein kind hätten die die schule und
durch die schule lina und und lehre
messe stellvertreten quasi den vermieter
dass sie mal den erwartungen von der
gesellschaft entsprechen und dass sie
nicht einfach nur mehr darauf indem es
kind muss und soll sondern dass sie
berechtigt die nato über über drei die
angst als kind ja was gibt was machte
mit kind sind das und das 1000 und der
abschluss nicht
diese gedanken haben sich auch die
radios gemacht und selen war ehrgeizig
und wollte alles richtig machen
[Musik]
das war ein langer weg für die ganze
familie
zero ds haben ihr leben umgestellt und
celine angepasst eltern kurse besucht
sich einer selbsthilfegruppe
angeschlossen und eben ritalin gegeben
vor einem jahr hat celine nun die
sektbar geschafft jetzt taucht die frage
auf wann sie fähig sein wird diesen
schul druck auch ohne ritter link zu
meistern
wirkliche sei es so dass der ihn trotz
zeit hat er ist der meinung dass man das
jetzt zählt probieren
das gefährt ist ja quasi nimmt und nach
nimmt sich einfach nehmen und gott wie
drinnen wie draußen sehr gute idee
gefunden das ist vor allem im sinn
willich rp es nimmt jemand medikament
und die kinder das ziel muss es ist aber
der konflikt das zählen das nicht gut
ich kann eigentlich nicht gab setzte
abermals jetzt aufsetzen ach ja da nicht
zwei züge mit dem zeugnis und damit er
machen was man sich noch über bewerber
waren dann note nehmen so gut sind wenn
man versucht hat zu ritalin absätze dann
ist das alles so gut und ich manchmal
probiere mit weniger will ganz absetzen
moment kann ich das nicht
wir stellen schon das fohlen zukunft und
das weiß ich weiß dass ich im moment
nicht wieder besetzen
irgendwann muss man natürlich schon
probieren will das ganze leben
ich hoffe es aber im moment nicht
celine nimmt seit sechs jahren 15
milligramm ritalin pro tag viel weniger
als kilian
obwohl sie viel schwerer ist aber sie
spricht auf eine geringe dosis gut an
ich habe mich besser konzentrieren
ich habe mich auch irgendwie
ich kann dann kann also ich bin ich ein
stress haben bin ich schon gestresst
aber ohne italien würde natürlich
irgendwie er war nämlich doch heute so
also als ich zum teil schon brutal
es geht aber der unterschied verschnitt
merkt dass ritalin dass sally nimmt
fällt unter das betäubungsmittelgesetz
ritalin gegner sagen darum es handle
sich um eine droge die abhängig macht
sachlicher sieht es als einziger es gibt
drei wissenschaftliche dort wo
abhängigkeit dokumentieren
das gibt es nicht und dort von der
medikamente eigentlich sie gehöre nicht
zu denen gruppen oder abhängigkeit
erfuhr abhängigkeit von dieser
abhängigkeit die speziell in sehr wohl
aber für sie überwiegen im moment die
vorteile
und kilian weil adhs medikamente
wirklich stark sind müssen die kinder
regelmäßig zur ärztlichen kontrolle
kilians kinderärztin betreut ihn seit
drei jahren und sieht oder hört ihn
mindestens einmal pro monat bei einer so
hohen dosis muss sie auch immer die
nebenwirkungen kontrollieren
es können schlafstörungen und
kopfschmerzen auftreten
die kinder essen weniger also hunger hat
prinzipiell nicht so am mittag ist
einfach ich bin halt immer weiterhin
strukturiert haben die ferien morgens
mittags ferry und nacht und ist aber er
ist wenig aber er ist immerhin aber am
abend dann wenn das konzert danach lässt
also dann ist da das ist super das toll
und das ist auch richtig so
wir sehen einfach mit der dosis recht
hoch aufgegangen weil erst dann er auch
gemerkt hat dass es ihm besser geht und
auch die lehrer gemerkt haben dass er
wirklich seine leistungen mit der hohen
dosis viel besser umsetzen kann
wir haben zwischendurch auch versucht
davon an das medikament umzusteigen
weil die dosierung auch sehr hoch ist
das war aber leider nicht erfolgreich
auch bei kilian geht es nun darum was
man mit dem medikament in den ferien
machen soll
daniela charity möchte gerne reduzieren
er hat 36 milligramm konnte er das soll
ich in die fähre macht es sinn wenn ich
unter graf 27 wenn jetzt das schul
trocknet da ist oder soll ich lasse ich
denke da sehr hoch dosiert ist
auf jeden fall probieren wenn du so viel
hass oder auch kilian du wenn du merkst
dass es wirklich dir nicht gut geht mit
der geringeren dosis kann man schon
wieder auf die normale hoch gehen aber
wenn er durch eine zeit lang mit einer
geringeren dosis auskommt wir haben
recht sowie adressiert ist
elke strauch arbeitet nicht nur
schulmedizinisch ritalin setzt sie
selten ein
sie sieht das medikament nicht als
lösung sondern als hilfestellung für die
kinder und sie findet vor allem den
leistungsdruck in unserer gesellschaft
überdenkenswert ich glaube unser system
passt zu nehmen nicht mehr ganz zu dem
was die kinder brauchen oder wie die
kinder sich verändert haben wir die
gesellschaft sich verändert hat und es
sind ja manchen klassen schon fährt mehr
nicht normale kinder das normale kinder
oder und von dem er denke ich ist es
schon noch ein großes gesellschaftliches
thema was davon zukunft und ich denke
wenn wir als gesellschaft umdenken
führen würden manche kinder gar nicht
auffallen oder oder könnten auch sich
selbst leben
das system kann man nicht so einfach
ändern der norm druck ist da und kilians
angst vor dem was in der dritten klasse
kommt die nimmt zu ich beschäftigt
[Musik]
erst sind aber mal ferien
für die reise ins ausland braucht
daniela cherokee einen betäubungsmittel
schein
abgemacht wird das kilian die dosis auf
27 milligramm reduziert
ferien ohne schul druck das hat der
kleine junge dringend nötig
bei anderen bricht gerade in den ferien
die welt zusammen russiker und sein team
mit winterthur haben verschiedene kinder
mit auswirkungen von adhs auf der
station
ein zwölfjähriger junge wollte sich mit
dem messer das leben nehmen und rastet
immer wieder aus es wird besprochen was
man mit ihm machen soll medikamente
nutzten bisher wenig wie ein solches
gefühl dass die wolfsburger bis
druckmittel findet sie wo ihr buch das
ihm einfach bis mit post aus druckmittel
bucht willi was erzähle ich sterbe dann
auch eine gewisse sachen erreichen wir
die worden ist hat uns so gut dass die
meisten eltern sind irgendwann am
anschlag
ein starkes adhs führt häufig zu
erziehungsprobleme glaubt tatsache das
kind wohl sagen jetzt die symptome
fieber fordert sie und je ausgeprägter
des stammes sieht das und ich verstehe
die ältere die materie der vater wurde
der grenze immer und er eigentlich
eigentlich denn dort wird dir so quasi
optimale erzeugt eine kgaa will sie
einfach den werden und das nicht
schaffen im kontext von der ganzen
familie und kristallen kontext vor den
apotheken war sie als eltern zwischen
gestellt also das ist für mich
nachvollziehbar
dies sind zurück aus den ferien sie
haben es geschafft das umfeld zu hause
für die ganze familie zu stabilisieren
es wird je länger je einfacher mit ziel
in palencia die ist dankbar und
irgendwie auch ein bisschen stolz
früher ist es für continental schluss
funden und jemand hat sie verstanden
und jetzt hat die grünen dienen und die
gegner zusammen und erzählen und ihre
alltagssorgen und ihre km nicht was mit
den anteilen und als ich morgens von
ganzem herzen gönnen ich mag das ein
riesenerfolg wenn man ob es wieder
zwischen toren im kurgarten wird wieder
sehr schwer die gestellt wo sie und ich
sehe mit ihren freundinnen gegangen
ihre freundinnen die wissen mittlerweile
bescheid
für ihn ist es wichtig dass sie es ihnen
gesagt hat
so überrascht sie aber die 1
minute als
das hindernis im weg so oder so ich bin
froh dass es so ein radikales vor ihnen
beim ritalin hat sich die 14-jährige
durchgesetzt wie kann der ortsteil
schöne davor bezüge dass ich ritalin
weiterhin vorne will er nach sei das
zweite schuljahr sehr streng wird und
wenn ich dann steuerlich absetzen und
ein paar minuten am schluss nach der
kompletten kader sind will ich meine
sogar kampflos andrea ist das auch nicht
so gut
mit ihren eltern erzählen abgemacht dass
sie das ritalin abzusetzen versucht
sobald sie es sich zutraut bei einigen
kindern gehen die symptome nach der
pubertät tatsächlich zurück andere
nehmen das medikament ein leben lang
[Musik]
und dominik ihm geht es auch ohne
ritalin jeden tag ein bisschen besser im
hapkido ist er voll dabei und mit den
kollegen läuft gut er wird jetzt auch
eingeladen und trifft sich mit seiner
neuen freundin zum spielen
das entlastet die situation zu hause
sehr wurde
meditationsübungen sind nach wie vor
nicht sein ding
nervös ist dominik immer noch aber er
hat selbstvertrauen gewonnen und kann
dadurch mit seinen schwächen besser
umgehen
und kilian in der innerschweiz
[Musik]
der kleine hat trotz medikament sehr
schwer der schulstart in die dritte
klasse ist nicht gut gelaufen
der druck nimmt weiter zu obwohl er mit
dem neuen lehrer gut auskommt mit den
klassenkameraden hat es gleich zu beginn
wieder streit gegeben
mit dem schulstoff kommt er nicht nach
er ist jeweils total kaputt wenn er nach
hause kommt und oft krank zudem stressen
in die vielen hausaufgaben
[Musik]
er hat der große große druck und es ihm
einfach nur wohl also dass äste
abbrechen msc schleizer man sieht daran
dass das kind wirklich ein starker druck
geht und dass augen für ihn mit zum
aushalten ist über den hausaufgaben
bricht kilian fasst zusammen
erfolgserlebnisse hat er kaum mehr
später schrieb er das okay
ehrlich
eher nicht ok interessant daniela
charity glaubt nicht mehr dass eine
sonderschulung innerhalb der klasse die
richtige lösung ist also mir eltern
wohnen können wirklich jetzt in eine
rundumbetreuung das bedeutet dass man
wird in sonderschulen tour dafür dass
ihm einfach mal wieder ich war so wie es
jetzt ich habe mir einfach an stress
kann aus dem ganze entstehen oder kann
er depressionen entwicklungszustand wie
sieht es mit schulverweigerern einfach
die sorge die treibt man den schuh mit
wilder druck ist ihm einfach zu groß und
wie lange wir durchhalten kann ich mache
haben schon die mutter hat nur noch ein
ziel druck abbauen
wir wünschen uns eigentlich dass er sich
so gut erholen kann das auch lehrer dass
er für sich und das erste gerät nicht
immer nur die niederschlag muss ich
rasiere wurde dauernd sind sind einfach
so dass er einfach darf sich entwickeln
wie er aber gleich ist
und kilian was wäre denn sein größter
wunsch
die wichtigste
[Musik]
kurz nach abschluss der dreharbeiten
kommt der entlastende bescheid
kilian soll sobald ein platz frei wird
in einer richtige sonderschule um
geteilt werden
[Musik]